thank you
[Music]
along the coast of Hawaii Volcanoes
National Park humpback whales are all
blue
every year these magnifs and animals
travel from Alaska in search of warmer
Waters
thank you
the Hawaiians call these 40-ton mammals
Kahola
[Music]
up to 12 000 make the epic journey
Hawaii is a much-needed Sanctuary to
this endangered species
a unique setting where ocean and lava
collide
[Music]
Hawaii is the only place in the U.S
where humpbacks breed and nurse their
young
born with very little fat calves would
soon freeze to death in the cold Waters
of Alaska
thank you
mothers come to these clear shallow
Waters to avoid predators
[Music]
that there's a catch
there's no food here
the moms go hungry
[Music]
losing up to 40 percent of their weight
raising their calves
[Music]
it's a sacrifice that pays off
humpback populations are increasing
[Music]
the park is just one place to see these
Giants of the deep
but they are not its biggest attraction
two massive volcanoes are
the first is Kilauea
one of the most active volcanoes on
Earth
the Lava Lake inside this crater can be
more than 750 feet deep
its lava flows can reach the sea 10
miles away
Kilauea is so big that even its Vents
and craters are huge
starting in 1983 one of these vents
erupted for 35 years
It produced so much lava that it covered
the Coast Road
bearing at more than 100 feet deep
to the West is the second volcano and
it's the biggest on the planet
this is Mauna Loa Rising more than 56
000 feet above its base
much taller than
Everest
the park exists thanks to eruptions over
hundreds of thousands of years
we're hard and lava forms a solid
foundation for life
close to the source poisonous gas fumes
escape from hot vents called fumaroles
this landscape is often swept clean by
molten lava
[Music]
it's one of the most Barren and toxic
environments on Earth
[Music]
Nature has had to adapt to living in
this land of Fire
a wingless lava cricket
after an eruption she is the first
creature to take up residence in this
hostile landscape
the ultimate pioneer
[Music]
no larger than a fingernail
he survives by eating morsels of food
that blow in with the ocean breeze
foreign
nobody knows where she comes from where
she goes or how long she lives
in many ways she's a mystery
[Music]
at some point known only to her
she'll leave
[Music]
the lava Cricket isn't the only unusual
resident that has adapted to this
extreme environment
[Music]
on these inhospitable slopes
there isn't any soil only hardened lava
where the Ohio tree
[Music]
it is one of the first plants to do so
after an eruption
growing from Tiny wind-blown seeds
this incredibly rugged tree anchors its
roots in cracks and crevices
[Music]
when toxic volcanic gases blow its way
the plant closes its breathing pores
called stomata
in essence
holding its breath
the Hawaiians Revere these trees
when they speak of people who are
skilled strong and beloved they refer to
them as Pua lahua or lahua blossoms
[Music]
they grow up to 100 feet tall
and can live over a thousand years
[Music]
thank you
over time the tough volcanic Specialists
will grow from gangly individuals
into incredible tropical forests
80 percent of Hawaii's native trees are
ohia lahula
another reason for their success is
their aerial root systems which draw in
moisture from the Pacific's tropical air
with roots in the air and digging deep
into the lava below
the ohia tree ensures its survival
and provides a home for other creatures
[Music]
the force are a biological treasure
a sanctuary for rare and Fantastical
native species
some are endemic
like the happy face spider
[Music]
found only in Hawaii
unlike many spiders she doesn't wait to
catch her prey in a web
but instead actively hunts for food
when she senses an insect nearby
she throws a sticky silk over it just
like a lasso
and hauls it in
there are also a few unwelcome visitors
[Music]
like the Jacksons three-horned chameleon
species was brought to Hawaii from East
Africa in the 1970s
[Music]
it is considered an invasive species
hunting native snails insects and
spiders it poses a threat to the
delicate balance of this magical forest
but there's another native creature here
that fights to keep the balance
this caterpillar is a special resident
in Hawaii Volcanoes National Park
commonly known as an inchworm
[Music]
these little herbivores have evolved to
blend in amongst the ohia blossoms
[Music]
please
but the cute little inchworm has a
killer cousin
which has a dramatically different
approach to getting food
[Applause]
[Music]
it's not pollen or nectar he's after
these are some of the only carnivorous
caterpillars
planet
he latches onto the branch with his rear
Pro legs and waits for a victim to come
close
with six front tarsal claws ready to
snatch his prey
he sits perfectly still until something
triggers his rear sensory bristles
[Music]
faster than the blink of an eye
he eats his prey alive
a magical forest growing on lava that's
home to a carnivorous caterpillar might
sound like fiction
but this park is where legends lore and
real life combine
trees rocks plants and animals can all
have connections to deities and spirits
nowhere is that connection stronger than
within the heart of Kilauea in the halei
ma'am crater
tradition holds this is the home of the
Goddess Pele
according to Legend Pele is the daughter
of the Earth Mother Papa
and Sky father wakia two of the most
ancient and revered of all Hawaiian gods
Pele is known as she who shapes the
sacred lands
ancient legends inspire people today and
shape much of Life throughout Hawaii
for over one thousand years Hawaiians
have cherished this land
they continue to strive to find balance
to protect their home
including Hawaii Volcanoes National Park
Dr Sam ohhugan is an advocate for
integration of Hawaiian values and
knowledge
our Traditions Place great value on
nature
the park is a protected place but that
protection extends beyond the park to
all of the islands of Hawaii
it's a sacred part of who we are as a
people
Hawaiians call their ancestor gods
aumakua
and they can take the form of native
plants and animals
such a form as a key no low a physical
manifestation of a deity
[Music]
when the gods are also your family and
the elements of nature their physical
presence your relationship with nature
is fundamentally transformed
of all the Hawaiian Traditional Values
the one most globally recognized today
is aloha
empathetic compassion
love
the Aloha that you extend the Family
extends further in Hawaiian thought to
all of the elements of nature around you
and your Aina
the lands of your place
this emerges as Aloha Aina
a deep appreciation and love for all the
features of the land such that you
realize that you are not whole without
your place
and that the fate and health of your
place is your own fate your own health
Hawaiians believe that this applies
across all lands on every island and
around the world
that connection extends to all of the
creatures on Earth
no matter where they call home or how
far they roam
[Music]
turtle called honu by Hawaiians is
making her way to the park
honu is an omakua a friendly spirit that
watches over and protects Hawaiian
families
[Music]
for years it's
she's heading for the shallow and
inviting Waters along Hawaii Volcanoes
National Park
[Music]
it's been lucky so far
only one in a thousand baby turtles
survive to adulthood
[Music]
but her greatest fight
may lay ahead
[Music]
a tiger shark off the coast of Hawaii
Volcanoes National Park is looking for a
hefty meal
a green sea turtle is just the ticket
out swimming the shark isn't an option
[Music]
but a clever defense might save her life
turning on her side makes her too big a
meal
a shark to get its jaws around
[Music]
she's not tiring
the shark is using up a lot of energy
[Music]
thank you
brains went out over Braun and the
turtle continues on her journey
green sea turtles have been protected
throughout the United States since 1978.
but the park was founded long before
then
thank you
it was established in 1916.
by President Woodrow Wilson
in order to protect these wild and
wonderful Landscapes
Hawaii Volcanoes National Park is one of
the oldest national parks in the U.S
but Hawaiians were here first
the park is filled with a rich cultural
tradition
[Music]
it's thought that early Hawaiians carved
these petroglyphs more than 500 years
ago using stones to etch the images deep
into the cooled lava
the carvings in the park form the
largest concentration of petroglyphs
anywhere in Hawaii
on land people plants and animals learn
to live alongside lava
but it also shapes life in the ocean
during an eruption flowing lava creates
channels Underground
these channels are lava tubes
created when molten lava cools on the
surface but continues to flow under
along the edges of the park where lava
meets the sea these Lava Tubes offer a
different type of opportunity for some
of the oceans fiercest sea dwellers
[Music]
here in the confines of the tubes
white tip reef sharks find safety from
larger predators
like the tiger shark
they look like they're asleep
but are simply in a deep state of calm
something that's easier to achieve in
the safety of the lava tubes
[Music]
thank you
amidst the Labyrinth exists another
species that's found a clever way to
survive in this fish eat fish world
the Hawaiian cleaner ass
[Music]
he provides an invaluable service that
the other Reef dwellers take full
advantage of
[Music]
like his name suggests he cleans all of
the residents big and little relieving
them of unwanted parasites broken scales
or mucus
the fish crowd around him jostling to be
next
[Music]
his striking colors and the way he moves
is a signal to other fish
[Music]
help
but
can every fish be trusted
the Hawaiian cleaner wrasse now
undertakes a somewhat terrifying task
[Music]
even the scariest of ocean dwellers rely
on him to help them survive
[Music]
what the reef shark might gain is a meal
is nothing compared to what it gets by
staying clean of parasites
[Music]
all life here is connected
creating unique opportunities in the
heart of the most fiery wonders within
the park
foreign
lava meets the sea
things get explosive
heat from the lava raises the water
temperature
minerals disperse the vital food source
for the ocean's smallest organisms
plankton
these tiny creatures are the precursors
to much of the wildlife that we know in
the sea
Plankton includes a wide range of
organisms such as bacteria
algae and microscopic animals
in one teaspoon of seawater as many as a
million single-celled Plankton can be
found
without them entire marine ecosystems
could
and along the coast of the big island of
Hawaii
the abundance of Plankton attracts a
creature
that seems out of this world
for divers with the desire for a unique
underwater experience
there's a once in a lifetime encounter
to be had
the hahalua is also known as The Reef
manta ray
[Music]
thank you
despite a formidable wingspan of up to
14 feet
they surprisingly only eat tiny plankton
these gentle Giants pose no threat to
people
[Music]
Reef manners have the largest brain size
of any fish
[Music]
they are highly intelligent
and recent experiments show self-aware
this trait is also shared by Dolphins
primates and elephants
[Music]
so it puts the Manta in a pretty select
club
[Music]
thank you
inside the park Pele wakes up
foreign
[Music]
there's little that can escape her Wrath
but once in a while
's Mercy can create a sanctuary that is
unlike any other place on Earth
this is a
it's the worst
Woodland spared by lava flows now
extremely isolated
seclusion creates the opportunity for
unimaginable islands of habitat
[Music]
this Forest has been cut off by
continual lava flows going back at least
8 600 years
life has evolved independently from
other areas on the island
thanks to a process known as adaptive
radiation the isolation of these kapucas
is behind the incredible number of
unique species that live here
[Music]
from as few as 250 original insect
species Hawaii is now home to more than
7 500.
[Music]
species may be found here that exist
nowhere else on Earth
not even in forests a few miles away
but there is a looming threat
rapid ohia death is a foreign fungal
disease
that the native trees are defenseless
against
even with the protection of the park up
to 90 percent of all infected trees die
[Music]
losing the ohia forest would be
disastrous not only for Hawaii Volcanoes
National Park but for the creatures that
depend on them
including a bird
considered to be one of the most
spectacular examples of evolution on the
planet
[Music]
Scarlet Hawaiian Honey creeper
there's been at least 59 different
species of Honey creepers throughout
Hawaiian history
[Music]
some scientists suggest they all
descended from a single ancestor
[Music]
the flowers of the ohia tree are their
main source of food
[Music]
that curvy beak is a special adaptation
that allows better access to nectar deep
within
[Music]
what may have started out as one species
of bird evolved into dozens of different
types each in their own little world
where once there were 59 species only 17
exist today the rest are sadly extinct
and there's another bird found here
who's custom built for this place
[Music]
this is a cousin of the Scarlet honey
creeper
he doesn't feed on nectar
he eats insects
an incredibly rare bird there are
approximately one thousand left in the
wild
the Hawaiian woodpecker he locates his
prey with his lower beak using it like a
pickaxe to dig
[Applause]
[Music]
the curved top beak gives him reach to
extract the tasty larva inside
[Music]
once again the park nurtures life in the
least expected places
[Music]
the ohia lehua tree has another surprise
in store
not only do its roots in the sky
help to capture precious moisture
they also delve deep beneath the ground
too
emerging and into an alien world
below the surface of Hawaii Volcanoes
National Park
there is a hidden and Mysterious World
like no other
deep inside the lava tubes that
crisscross Underground
The Roots dangle through the cave
ceiling they help to transport and
provide an essential ingredient for life
water
while the lava tubes may seem like
they'd be Barren of life it turns out
these roots provide an environment for
rare insects
cave biologists from around the U.S have
been studying the communities of animals
living in the lava tubes
recently a research team discovered a
remarkable number of new species
the new discoveries hint at what may yet
be found
we're still learning how these hidden
places are connected and essential to
life above ground
where some lava tubes are seemingly
inaccessible
others welcome us into their mysterious
depths
this tunnel was created over 500 years
ago by a river of molten lava that
exceeded temperatures of 2 000 degrees
Fahrenheit
this is nahuku where Thurston lava tube
one of the most visited sites in Hawaii
Volcanoes National Park
it's part of the network of tunnels that
spans more than 40 miles from Kilauea
sending 3 600 feet beneath the surface
it is the longest and deepest lava tube
Network on the planet
the park has more than half a million
visitors every year
but humans are not the only species to
keep coming back
[Music]
after thousands of miles and more than
20 years in Sea a female green sea
turtle returns to the parks inshore
waters
this is a
[Music]
visible
foreign
but first she needs a bit of a cleanup
[Music]
over the years her shell has become
covered in algae
it doesn't hurt her
but it does slow her down
until now there wasn't anything she
could do about it
today
she's in luck
foreign
s offer a unique cleaning service
[Music]
it's a symbiotic relationship
[Applause]
[Music]
the turtle gets clean
and the fish get a meal
[Music]
foreign
she'll find her way back to the beach
where she was born
there she'll lay her eggs and continue
the circle of life
[Music]
the some residents return others leave
winter break is over it's time for the
humpbacks to begin their migration back
to the cooler Waters of Alaska
the numbers have grown
[Music]
foreign
has been productive
and the Cavs are strong enough to embark
on the 3 000 mile Journey
the humpbacks keep in constant contact
through complex vocalizations
[Music]
oh
some of their low frequency calls can
travel through water up to ten Thousand
Miles
[Music]
next year the whales will return to this
special place like so many visitors to
the park choose to do
[Music]
the park was born from lava
how it continues
[Music]
foreign
that make the island bigger
[Music]
but the park is so much more than just
volcanoes and lava
every day in Hawaii Volcanoes National
Park can reveal something new and
unexpected
[Music]
the land and its inhabitants live in a
precious balance
[Music]
attention Hawaiians knew
it and we recognize it today
[Music]
foreign
by understanding how important this
place is to all of us
we become part of something bigger than
just the park
something essential
memorable legendary
[Music]